names Max Lombardi and I've been an
agent for ten goddamn years you want to
know what it's like let me tell you
about the Lombardi tails
well [ __ ] yeah yeah I'd say you got the
bastard I don't get much more dead than
that okay calm down you're not gonna get
deke last breathe kid here's what
happened you're not the one who shoved
him off the building with a live grenade
you were doing your honest best to
follow orders and take the bastard alive
you were doing just fine too until
nobody killed him well yeah obviously
someone killed him I meant nobody the
person are people or whatever you've
heard of nobody right yeah yeah that one
does mysterious [ __ ] helps Hertz's and
then he disappears he's the one who did
it
understand no it's not exactly lying
okay so it's lying but it's lying to
cover your ass which is practically a
moral obligation at this point look you
know so I'm gonna let you in on a little
secret
everybody wants things to be simple they
want the world that make sense even the
higher-ups sure they know the world's
[ __ ] up but they want it [ __ ] up in
a way they understand things out here in
the field they get messy sometimes we
got to do things they wouldn't
understand and sometimes we make honest
mistakes the higher-ups don't want to
think that sort of thing happens with
their hands and eyes we go out we fix
problems for them so as far as they're
concerned we always do it the way they
want like sometimes maybe you end up
needing help from outside well no but
the other guys in the GOC know the MC
and D or hell even in the CI we trade
favors when we have to but the
higher-ups wouldn't understand it and
they'd [ __ ] it all up or maybe they want
us to take something that alive that
turns your blood into fire by looking at
yeah never mind how are you supposed to
get it done we do what we got to do we
try to make the mission go through
sometimes that means we've got to do
things they wouldn't like
sometimes it means we cut our losses and
then when you write up the report you
gotta make everything nice and neat in a
way the higher-ups understand that's
where nobody comes in
everyone knows nobody does [ __ ] that
doesn't make sense sometimes he helps us
gives us information works with us
sometimes it comes in and [ __ ] it up
the higher-ups they understand about
nobody then I like him but they accept
he exists and there's no much we can do
about it so when we write up these
reports
he's real handy for tying up loose ends
the end of the day the mission gets done
the best we can do it and the higher-ups
get a story they can swallow so kid you
didn't do it you tried to take the skip
and alive but nobody got in the way
said some mysterious crap I'll come up
with that and then he left before we
could stop him maybe jumped off the
rooftop he does [ __ ] like that after all
he's nobody is he real I don't know kid
ask him yourself sometime
you